reject nation the time has come to watch
stranger things
season four
part one last season we had olivia with
us but we are in the middle of moving
right now so she is doing all the
manhandling for that so i could enjoy
the show with you guys that's really
nice
and she's working a full-time job on top
of that too maybe my part two should be
back but anyway guys i'm excited for
this i rewatched all the stranger things
a couple months ago so i am like
i'm free to inject this into my friends
let's do this guys full length watch
laundry sticking with the time code will
be over at our patreon page for super
sexy rejects cover a whole bunch of
shows and movies over there as well some
of the shows exclusive reaction
highlights included but if you can't do
that please leave a like and a comment
that'd be very much appreciated also
very important subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for stranger things is
up because we're going to be binge in
this series so with that in mind we'll
probably keep the reviews a little bit
short up until we're at the final
episode and then boys at prepper you
guys are helping us get through all
these shows in june so thank you let's
do it
wow he's a smart individual
none of those words are the correct
answers
it's probably brenner
pop is back
if you didn't know that by season four
something's wrong
going through all the greatest hits
[Applause]
[Music]
wow all the kiddos
are you up for some more lessons
oh ten it's supposed to be a dog
it looks like a cow
you're gonna get killed i want you to
find dr ellis
why are they screaming
you should you should go there bro
[Music]
that was the first time dr brunner died
[Laughter]
and not the last
holy balls
whoo
oh my god wow
hardcore
so many dead kids so many mangled kids
jeez
oh my god did she do it she did it oh
man
what have you done
oh you're a murderer
[Music]
yep there goes all my theories about
seeing more of the kids
that spin-off we tried to do not at all
except for eight joyce says time is
funny like that
emotions can make it speed up or slow
down
we are all time travelers if you think
about it
hint
i have to make something called a visual
aid
cool
a little hop
will is painting a lot
but he won't show me he's so much bigger
his funny friend argyle has been taking
us to school
his hair is longer than mine and he and
jonathan like to smoke smelly plants
together
[Laughter]
but definitely not do cocaine
miss you
love
out
[Music]
what the hell are you doing it's ten
after oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
30 seconds okay i have to find my pants
got a hellfire club shirt i want you
home no later than nine tonight yeah
okay i'll try no no trying i need to go
to bed early tonight why it's a 6 30
flight nine or no california
oh i love her 80s trainer outfit
[Music]
oh smart
try tigers 86
tigers 86 copy that
do you see it yeah i see it
oh no
steady
easy
i will repent later
[Music]
in latin rule
what a great girlfriend she returned
five times positive 53 minutes five
seconds do you know who pauses fast
times at 53 minutes five seconds
i like boobies you like boobies
we all like [ __ ] everyone loves
boobies
[Applause]
[Music]
they should have played the stranger
themes
there will be a marching band remakes of
events
[Music]
[Applause]
think of heather
think of billy
think about our heroic police chief jim
hopkins
think about each and every one of our
friends
let's win this game for them and that's
exactly what we do
and i brought them all back basketball
save talks
how is that possible they call it a
tournament if you win one game you go on
to play the next until there's only one
team left
[Applause]
god damn it lucas ah you're ruining the
gang again this is the championship game
and this is the end of eddie's campaign
a semester of adventuring has led to
this moment and we need you yeah and the
tigers don't you've been on the bench
all year ouch
i'm tired
of being bullied we came to high school
wanting things to be different i skipped
tonight that's all out the window just
talk to eddie get him to move hellfire
come to my game
please
oh man it's a lot to ask there bud be 25
in high school is tough
get all the support you can get
have you ever wished you could have the
answer to any question right at your
fingertips oh god
yes it's just like those those big fancy
books you see on tv
she saw an encyclopedia yep
in russia postage stamps you
[Laughter]
come on let's go
[Music]
call murray
jane
so she does go by jane now
[Applause]
will always looks at her so much so much
nervousness
are you okay
i know you don't have powers anymore
still
for my hero
i chose my dad
and for my visual aid
i made
a dirayama
of our cabin more like diarrhea
i want to kick your ass so bad he made
the best eggos
and
we like to watch miami vice
[Music]
i'm just like confused i thought this
was a presentation about a historical
hero my dad was in the newspaper your
local paper
that's not news you idiot
he saved lots of lives
in a mall fire
so sorry mrs gracie i didn't mean to
interrupt
i just wanted clarity on the rules of
the assignment that teacher won't just
cut her off hell
it wasn't that bad friends don't lie i'm
not lying
oh
time for a heavy metal makeover
millie bobby brown
phenomenal on this man
so consistently phenomenal
[Music]
uh what just happened does captain
basketball just break up with her well
she's working two jobs
so it's not easy it must not be easy for
you either with your stepdad gone it's
kind of better
honestly better how
not being abused but
i know you never want to go to any of my
games but this one is kind of a big deal
a big deal lucas you really care about
this yeah i do but maybe you should find
something you care about too
oh buddy oh god david lucas
people just change
okay
that's it
i've changed
ah ouch
she's terrific you know how hard it is
for kids to understand grief
sadie sink man she's great too
you're all right
please just go away
are you deaf i said go away
chrissy
mom
you're ready to try on the dress again i
loosen the back a little for you
what
oh my god
oh god it's like a freddy krueger like
villain
this is our first taste of vector
oh wow
literally feeds on your traumas
at first regarded as a heartless game of
make-believe now has both parents and
psychologists concerned
[Music]
satanic panic
ritual sacrifice
sodomy
suicide and even
ramirez in the ship
lucas has to do his uh
falls and laundry baskets game so
he's not gonna be able to make it to
hellfire
tonight smooth
so me and mike
we were talking
shooting the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we might
postpone wow
[Laughter]
i'm gonna snatch that diploma i'm gonna
run like hell out of here
yeah you say that last year and the year
before that yeah yeah this is different
this year
it's my year what's going to say it
looks like it's 25 years
there's a lot of older than him yep
well i'm here to tell you that there are
other little hostilities out there
who need help and all you guys gotta do
is get your peeps on and go and find one
it's like multi-level marketing that's
what real friendship is like you
received a doll in the mail he's a black
belt
i'm sure we'll see his moves it's
cracked
cracked yeah like the porcelain cracked
and they tried to glue it back together
okay okay uh do you have rope and
something heavy
what for
smashing
all right hammer i was like why rope
yeah
you want to drop something on it
one time come on i want to hang out with
you and eddie the freak munson uh
yeah pass you're just jealous because i
have another older male friend
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
no
no
i hate high school
screw high school
what oh we're going to junior high to
recruit
she had lucas's sister
this is a good idea
[Laughter]
this is my normal walk to home
[Laughter]
hello
fascinating
hey
sorry didn't mean to scare you
you okay
still hear the chimes
oh my god he does do satanistin
it's time for a ritual
i do a half ounce for uh
20 what do you say
plenty of bang for your buck should last
you a while
half ounce for 20. what a good deal jeez
middle school talent show you're doing
this cheer thing and i
i was with my band corroded coffin
[Music]
do you have anything
stronger
[Music]
satanist rituals
i've got some dog blood here
that's the necronomic yeah
oh my god
i am so sorry
i hope mr fitly is okay
such a [ __ ]
the worst kind too
i cannot wait for you kids to die
[Laughter]
did someone do this
i tripped
all right angela oh
[Music]
we'll fix it together okay
[Music]
i guess this isn't just
wacky ass experiments sure
she's that lady in the neighborhood
i guess this makes sense because you
want some distance in case it explodes
we want to make sure that we destroy
that doll with as much force as possible
one more thing
are you there talk to me
what happened
broke
do you see a bug anything with wires
[Laughter]
yes the riddler yes
pop is a lie
who sent in the clues
top speaking in third person
[Music]
many managed to ship a box and yeah
must not be too oppressed
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
we took a massively hard class oh come
on just tell her come on
sorry she was the girl talking about in
the bathroom that's right okay
[Music]
let's do this
[Music]
with the flag
usa usa
my name is lady applejack and i'm a
chaotic good half elf rogue level 14.
and i'll smile as i watch them die we
gonna do this
or we gonna keep chit chatting like this
is your mommy's book club
welcome to hellfire
[Applause]
i'll probably never even know lucas was
gone
[Applause]
we're saving hawkins all your traumas
are asleep
sadness death killed my cat so it was
thought my friend so it was thought but
vecna
[Music]
69 dudes
he only has 15 hit points left don't be
[ __ ] [ __ ] really cause we're not
delusional
[Laughter]
let's kill the son of a [ __ ] winners
find a way to win let me find a way
chances of success
a lot of
mirroring segments happening in this
episode yeah
lucas lucas
lucas
oh come on do it lucas
and erica
team sinclair
james and claire
[Music]
you're gonna be popular lucas
[Music]
sinclair's crush
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
damn
it was a cathartic couple of victories
right there
[Applause]
and now with tomorrow's assembly i'm
gonna take credit for how you made that
three-pointer
[Applause]
[Music]
and what a great game it was alan ending
with a dramatic buzzer beater from bench
warmer lucas sinclair he must be feeling
on top of the world right he must love
hearing us refer to his benchmark she
was listening
yeah first will last season was
feeling like he was being left behind
with the group
[Music]
what's got you all riled up good boy
[Music]
this is uh
my castle
oh [ __ ]
yeah
kick in pretty quick
oh [ __ ] you sure you have it no no no i
got it um
somewhere
sorry i'm late sweetheart
right
it's a warlock i have one of those
you're just like this guy i am this guy
hair down for all future reactions
a lot of messing with time in this
episode christopher nolan consulted on
this
there's one person who knows how to do
time
mom you're going to look
absolutely beautiful
[Music]
peaceful bliss just moments away
chrissy
oh
fascinating
chrissy hello
[Music]
[Music]
cool
she's gonna die isn't she
[Music]
[Music]
it's time
for your suffering
to end
oh
god wow
all that judges dragons man and the
devil's lettuce
so much worse than i thought
that was so much worse than i expected
it to be that was that was
damn that was
that was
metal this show gets violent but that is
one of the most violent things i think
this series has done that's disgusting
yeah wow so painful and visceral
that was i was
i was taking a background violet that
was yeah
yeah man
[Music]
whoa
that's hardcore
yeah that was brutal with an umlaut over
the you
i like that these episodes are so long
they really take their time to breathe
like this is transported man oh yeah
oh yeah and it it's the perfect kind of
halfway point between a feature movie
and it
just one of these is like five minutes
short of your future yeah yeah
absolutely but but at the same time
this was a great really lovely paced
episode yeah
especially when you're going to
introduce new characters yeah you got to
introduce new characters you got to
catch up with everybody you got to set
the stage and you got to build the
tension without going too ham too fast
and i thought they'd
absolutely achieve that here and i like
the the new character or the new villain
you know like we've seen them before
like
i think what's interesting is so much of
the time like
every preceding season even the first
season every character's dealing with
their traumas and it's so much about
overcoming their traumas
you know in order to to win the day
and to have a villain that specifically
feeds on your traumas is a cool
direction to take your your next villain
in stranger things and also a
villain presumably from the upside down
it seems that um is also humanoid and
humanoid to an extent
like
uh humanoid and speaks as well
versus uh you know like incepting your
mind or you know organs
yeah it is a it is a different direction
to to take it uh so yeah there's a lot
here there's more to talk about damn wow
all right so ideally we want to keep
these discussions short because uh but
there's so much to get through
but they put so much effort into each
episode yeah that you want to like break
it all down uh yeah there's so much to
to unpack here so you know it's like and
i know usually by the time people are
watching our reactions they're already
like
like honestly they're done with the show
yeah they're already done with the show
you know so i get it i get it and and uh
but this this in particular for your
pilot to return
it's
there's so much depth in it and they
seem to be dropping a lot of clues about
time travel like a lot of us have
suspected that there might be some type
of time travel quality a russian doll
already like right at the
beginning of this story
and um you know edit everything with the
clocks and the way they
called
how would you
explain that that like when you're
cutting back and forth through a series
of events when you're intercutting like
two sequences that mirror each other in
terms of yeah the action as well as the
sentiments spoken or whatever that is
yeah there's a lot of that in this
episode i don't know if it was to like
get through the setup or if that was a
thing that was also thematically tying
in with the whole time element i think
it is i think i think there's definitely
a time motif and there's also definitely
a sort of mirror's motion
it's okay this is this is what dustin
has to do with our dna
uh but yeah i thought that the there is
a definite mirroring and paralleling
motif that they do definitely within
those montages and within those inner
cuts between yeah uh that sort of
exquisite corpse style like they're both
basically saying the same thing in two
different scenarios but there's also i
think
in a way where you know you watch moon
knight and it's like yes it's very easy
to tell there are million reflections
and mirrors and that's part of the motif
but i thought this also has that in the
the visual in the settings there are a
lot of things that are played out off of
mirrors or glass or reflections
and things like that and and i think
they lace those things together visually
as well really nicely along with yeah
the cutting and stuff like that
if i had
one
little um
i don't even know it's a nitpick because
i i i want this is why you people binge
watch i want to wait to see how the rest
of the season uh unfolds is that after
wanting you know a season four for so
long i was surprised how it felt like
most of the time was not spent with the
returning characters but with the new
characters yeah like they gave a lot of
focus to eddie
like so much focus eddie and chrissy
yeah yeah that's about it
everybody
but yeah it's like you have to edit it's
not like this is eddie's episode it
really does yeah cause you got a playset
for the entire ensemble you gotta
establish some core conflicts and then
established to the new situation going
and i think yeah i'll wait to see how
they do it but for a first episode i did
kind of appreciate that because as the
trauma you know continues and as this
villain dives directly into character's
traumas i wonder if they're going to now
kind of uh expand the themes into you
know traumas shared by communities and
generational traumas and things like
that and other things definitely what i
was picking up on yeah because i talked
to the basketball player the basketball
player to another basketball yeah yeah
absolutely that that really uh leaned in
on not sorry to control but yeah his
speech was very much about like hawkins
community yeah and so it feels
sensible from here right now that they
would start that way and that they might
be bolstering the heft of the overall
scope of the story with that stuff but
at the same time yeah
it hit me most when we cut back to 11
when they uh in the scene that was
released as a clip where she runs into
uh the bullies and they smash her
diorama uh like that was the moment
where i was like oh wow that's right we
really are doing a lot and we haven't
seen 11 except for in these couple
scenes even yeah um so
my my guess is yeah the next one we'll
we'll dive further into our main
ensemble again i mean gosh this creature
preys on 11's traumas there's an
interesting set up though you know to go
from the early days of dr brenner
i don't know if it was ever made clear
that 11 was the one who offed the rest
of the kids
part of me now is wondering if that is a
mislead or because if you look at the
way chrissy died and if you look at the
way all the kids died it's that same
like all their limbs were twisted and
snapped around and so i wonder if it's
meant to look like eleven did all that
when really she might have been fighting
fighting ah
but i assume they will eventually call
vector yeah yeah yeah
i think they they said they call i think
the duffer brothers or someone said is
yeah i forget some details of what i've
learned in the past
which if that's what they say about
lucas being on the basketball team i
don't remember that that was told or not
if that was shown in trailers
he's shown in the jersey yeah is it yeah
okay i don't remember that now and for
him to feel like there is there is sort
of an interesting migration of that plot
line of like ah every season one of the
kids is feeling especially alienated
from the group yeah
i mean it's part of this goes in theme
with stranger things of growing up
you know yeah and i like the way that
the the tone and the 80s style is able
to grow up with them like this felt more
like a teen summer movie you know than
perhaps like the the e.t or goonies type
of inspirations of seasons past
i've i thought
i guess i get my dates all mixed up i
was like i thought that jonathan would
be done with high school now
i know we're like working at a newspaper
in high school yeah
that's not half these people graduate
oh never mind i guess i'm getting my
dates mixed up on because i don't
remember this last season took place in
summer i don't think they were in actual
school it was fourth of july yeah yeah
you'd be in the midst of summer yes yes
yes okay so it makes sense and now it's
spring yeah okay yeah 185 days all right
so we're into everybody's last year
that's right they were working a summer
job at the newspaper i was just like i
thought you were done with school and
now getting jobs yeah
my memory was uh serving me incorrectly
but i got some fun little easter eggs
with tammy i remember now that they were
talking robin and
uh and steve were talking in the in the
bathroom that one episode and they they
bonded over uh tammy yeah so you have
that
um
and then dustin's girlfriend coming back
right away
not the last time we'll see her oh man
no she's gotta keep coming back but yeah
i i do want moving forward to spend time
with the characters we've grown to love
over the years and like really make that
the focus but you know that's why i said
like it for for returning and to have
your episode length be as as thick as it
is and for all of them to be really long
i think it's you know if this was
shorter i might have more of an issue
with that yeah um but no that was a
gripping ending you know yeah
well it made really well what was what
was uh
if i'm not mistaken when they get
transported to the upside down in the
previous seasons
they
they're actually transported even when
will
remember what the rules are
remember when they went
trick-or-treating in season two in their
ghostbusters outfit will was
he had he had uh the camcorder and then
he
got transported and he fell down and
then i remember uh mike was like well
where are you and he was like standing
right there he couldn't see him yeah
so here when they're transported it's
all is within the mind yeah it's like a
telepathic link or something like that
oh that's crazy it's the sense that i
got yeah so it also mutates then the way
in which the upside down interacts with
its hosts
yeah i mean we got uh we we got to catch
up with a lot more of our characters
because there's a lot of things we
already have a lot of characters and now
we're introducing you always got way
more than i expected is more than i
expected one isn't plenty yeah obviously
with a cast that's big you've got a
whole hellfire club yeah yeah and then
yeah all these other kids on the
basketball and the cheerleading squad
i feel like the basketball guy's going
to be bigger and that's going to lead to
some trouble now with the whole freaking
yeah between lucas and his friends yeah
oh no the i was thinking the basketball
player and and uh eddie
oh that too i mean yeah his girlfriend
died at the
his uh yeah he's probably gonna get
accused of murder and oh my god the
dungeons and dragons yeah things are
going to be really bad for yeah for
eddie pretty fast but no i i thought
this was i think what they said about
wanting to be more horror they really
committed to that
um you know like season three got a
little bit goofy and a lot more
comedic very junior year
yeah but especially with them all
getting a bit older too i think it's
very natural to then advance the grade
of horror that they're willing to go to
yeah this feels more um yeah they always
up the cinematic quality and it feels
more in tune with like what we have with
season one and two in terms of tone and
style and they can really take their
time for those character be like i love
that therapy scene with max like exactly
and the scene with eddie and christy in
the woods was really charming like you
can yeah do all the play setting you
would have to do in like 45 minutes but
then actually give some time to also
breathe and some actual character
endearment and some actual emotionality
into the scenes too yeah yeah so this is
character eddie is he older or is it
he's been like held back a few years
yeah but he performed for christie's
junior high
they were in
the ad like they were in school together
and they did a talent show and now that
they're in high school i think he's just
been held back so much like maybe he was
a bit older than her maybe he's been
like two or three years held back or
something like that gotcha gotcha
uh
so but then again
yeah
he has so many friends who play dungeons
just so many one
and i do appreciate the way that they
cut that montage between the dnd game
and the basketball game because i've
never really witnessed a dungeons
dragons game uh and i'm sure there's way
more to it than even that and i know
there are a million web series where
people do it on camera but this was one
where i was like i really love that
they're cutting back and forth between
these two things and giving me some
vague sense of how this all works and it
does look pretty fun it looks time
consuming but it looks really fun
i used to love a good imagination game
and there was a line um
that i remember in season three a line
that was
that could have either been taken one of
two ways with will of i forget exactly
what it was but a lot of people were
like did he mean that
he just doesn't care for girls and he
just wants to hang out with his friends
or was he implying that he's actually
gay
and then they had that moment there in
the classroom where that girl tried
touching him and and uh playing footsies
and he was like get away from me see i
don't know what to think now yeah
because i feel like almost that they
want us to think he's gay and then
they're gonna
reveal him as somebody can't have two
gay people two gay characters they're
gonna review maybe they'll hey i mean
maybe they'll reveal him as asexual
that's the thing too that doesn't get
brought up very often might as well make
it happen but it almost seems like
something else is happening that we
can't because i feel like it would be
very easy to go uh maybe he's gay or
else he just doesn't like that
particular girl or whatever well nelly
bop everyone's great still millie bobby
brown excellent as always uh she's just
such a like she's my favorite character
um a lot of people said like she's an
easy one to her hopper the easiest ones
to go to
but uh no specifically her like her
acting is just so unbelievably
phenomenal oh yeah the little nuances
about her her speech and vocabulary and
all that stuff like i will say my
association with finn wolfhard has
definitely changed over the years i used
to see mike now i see finn wolf
throwback extraordinaire very aware of
finn wolfhard
that's my goal for the czar so everyone
else i just see the characters even one
node of writer i just
i just see finn wolfhard that's my
biggest hope for this season is that it
can get me back to just seeing him as
the character
because so much of what i understand
about finn wolfhard is just mike
yeah well the first two seasons i i saw
mike and then for some reason in season
three i'm like i don't know why i'm just
aware of like i feel like you're playing
mike but you're you're not really mike
yeah yeah because i've seen so much of
finn wolfhard in my life and all these
other things now well and so much of him
is very similar to mike anyways so i
feel like the lines kind of have to blur
i don't know if you're writing like
interviews and stuff he comes across a
little like cooler confident actor kid
yeah but it's but it never seems like
man he's really created a character here
like i i feel like the things he do not
to like
i feel like he's not as nerd i feel like
mike is so much more nerdy and
and like when i see interviews and stuff
he comes across like i'm a little cool
but i feel like that sarcastic and that
quick wit is still in there sure sure
yeah you know just just yeah
i still can film all four he pleased
ghostbusters after life
i mean fair enough yeah
yeah yeah the guy who's like i want the
guy who specifically says i want bill
hader to play the older me
[Laughter]
oh hey could you imagine if stranger
things did an it thing where eventually
we see them all as adults maybe you can
make it out get that it casting right
back in here yeah i always like him and
i wouldn't want the show i don't want
that to be a misconception i wouldn't
want this show without phil wilvardo no
he totally
dna yeah yeah i would not feel the
complete without him 100
um
yeah and i am worried jonathan will
still get a little bit pushed to the
background again
like yeah
it was last season hey
they'll find something like that to be
important they're setting up that
they're gonna find flaws in their
relationship
i guess that's the thing i i don't know
i feel like yeah the most interesting
thing they had was like oh she's gonna
choose him over steve and then the rest
of the time they're like okay cool how
do we make jonathan engaging now
yeah season three wasn't that engaged i
loved him in the first season and i
really liked them a lot and carry on in
the second season but yeah third season
he was
definitely pushed a little bit to the
backdrop
so
yeah i mean they're all everyone's still
great and uh we we've got long ass
episodes for a reason and you know
anyone who didn't really spend time with
i'm sure we're going to spend time with
them in other episodes do a whole
episode on argyle alone yeah this is but
for a setup it still managed to feel
like incredibly engaging and different
it does feel more late 80s yeah yeah
yeah which is i think is a really fun
it's a very specific part of the 80s
it's late 80s yeah yeah and i mean some
people claim 86 and 87 specifically is
some of the best years for pop culture
ever and so they they definitely come
with distinct
and yeah i feel like yeah you're
reaching like peak 80s at that point
yeah
all right guys well thank you for being
here keep a lookout for our reaction in
the next episode we don't know how these
are going to be uploaded we got a lot of
shows
so
yeah just bear with us as we're going
but hey we'll just keep a lookout and
last but not least let's let's shout out
some patrons
archangel gabriel alexis venus and
serena williams mitchell reed you do
good deeds t he he nmb
jimmy burns i want your ashes in a yearn
alan ling playing with my thing
logan burton my butt's hurting from all
the
twerking you did for me i hope i didn't
overuse my rhymes
don't fear
when you got kyra eric cons 39 you read
my mind when you decided to pledge do
you see cousy cousy because i see cousy
cousy phil eider i'm no longer in dire
and i will call you my sire bearer in
the garage not in a lodge because bears
are from the woods nick x you are the
bats
i get euphoria when i think of juan
longoria gail ferguson
[Laughter]
jaren wanner bon von milano
cliff rodriguez i'll do it if you tell
me to suck on your eggs
chris brings me loss of bliss busting
nuts and stuff
master t you're a real g who brings me a
lot of glee
fanny i'm in heaven with john the goat
seven pseudonymous entity i love you for
eternity will you please join my
fraternity yeah and burn with me whoa
yearn for freedom
guys and girls and everything in between
i want to thank you all for being part
of our patreon page and show your
support at this specialty
um a little bit helps right now
especially now you're hiring a lot more
editing hours these days so thank you
guys so much keep this real rejects
train chugging along with the help of
you guys oh you guys suck with you soon
[Music]